Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Human rights did not begin with the French Revolution, and I do not think anyone who knows their religious history or their Greek history would suggest they did. We had 1689, our silent, quiet revolution, where Parliament exerted its will over the King. It was not the sort of revolution that France's was. It was done quietly, without the bloodshed.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。人权并非始于法国大革命，我想任何了解宗教史或希腊史的人都不会这么认为。我们有 1689 年那场静悄悄的革命，议会在此期间将意志强加于国王。那与法国的革命截然不同，它是悄无声息地完成的，没有流血。
Liberty, equality, fraternity. They forgot obligations and duties, I think. And then, of course, it was the fraternity that went missing for a long time. Well, it just did, did it not? It heralded an age of terror. Some of the arguments used, oh, you have to strike these people down because they will be counter-revolutionaries. Oh, what familiar language to my generation. They have to be struck down, murdered, and not just the way the terrors were done, but with people loving to see the torture. Oh, it was an age of terror. It was an age of terror.
自由、平等、博爱。我认为他们忘记了义务和责任。当然，博爱在很长一段时间里都缺失了。嗯，事实确实如此，不是吗？它开启了一个恐怖时代。所用的一些论点是，哦，你必须打击这些人，因为他们会成为反革命分子。哦，这对我们这一代人来说是多么熟悉的语言。他们必须被打击、被谋杀，而且不仅仅是以那种恐怖统治的方式，还要让人们乐于看到酷刑。哦，那是一个恐怖时代。那是一个恐怖时代。
So, Dominic, that was top enthusiast for the ideals of the French Revolution. Margaret Thatcher, who was interviewed by Le Monde on the 11th of July, 1989. So just three days before the bicentenary of the fall of the Bastille. And I remember it very well because I was in Paris for the bicentenary and the G7 was being held. So there were interviews with all the leaders of the G7 and Mrs. Thatcher was the only leader who didn't come out with platitudes about how wonderful the French Revolution had been. And I remember when the cavalcades went through the streets, there were great cheers for all the other six leaders and she had the honour of being the only person to be booed. So it's a reminder of the fact that the French Revolution is incredibly controversial, isn't it? Incredibly divisive. Divided opinion back in 1989 still divides opinion today. There
那么，多米尼克，那是法国大革命理想的头号拥护者。玛格丽特·撒切尔夫人于 1989 年 7 月 11 日接受了《世界报》的采访。就在巴士底狱陷落两百周年前三天。我记得很清楚，因为当时我正在巴黎参加两百周年纪念活动，七国集团峰会也在那里举行。当时对七国集团的所有领导人都进行了采访，撒切尔夫人是唯一一位没有对法国大革命的伟大发表陈词滥调的领导人。我记得当车队穿过街道时，其他六位领导人都受到了热烈的欢呼，而她却有幸成为唯一一个被嘘的人。所以这提醒我们，法国大革命是一个极具争议的话题，不是吗？极其容易引起分歧。1989 年时意见分歧，今天依然如此。
are lots of historians who would agree with Mrs. Thatcher and lots who would violently disagree. And I think what that reflects is... Violently? Yeah, violently. Yes. Terroristically, shall we say. I think the French Revolution is the central political event in modern history. Obviously, there are other things that compete. The Russian Revolution, most obviously. Or the American Revolution. But I agree, neither of those really compare. No.
有很多历史学家会同意撒切尔夫人的观点，也有很多人会强烈反对。我认为这反映了……强烈地？是的，强烈地。是的。我们可以说是恐怖主义式的。我认为法国大革命是现代史上核心的政治事件。显然，还有其他事件与之竞争。最明显的是俄国革命，或者美国革命。但我同意，这两者都无法真正与之相比。是的。
I think the French Revolution, I'm sure we'll be talking about this in subsequent episodes, but to me, the French Revolution is the paradigmatic example of people trying to reboot a society, to make it again, to make something new. So it's that on the one hand. And then, of course, there are other dimensions to it. It becomes the great crucible of conservatism. It's in response to the French Revolution. Edmund Burke writes the most famous example of literary conservatism in history. It's reflections on the revolution in France. It's the French Revolution that exports the idea of the nation and of modern nationalism across Europe and arguably the world. And its iconography, Tom, we're still so familiar with it.
我认为法国大革命——我相信我们会在后续剧集中讨论这一点——对我来说，法国大革命是人们试图重启社会、重塑社会、创造新事物的典型范例。所以一方面是这样。当然，它还有其他维度。它成为了保守主义的伟大熔炉。正是为了回应法国大革命，埃德蒙·伯克写下了历史上最著名的文学保守主义著作——《对法国大革命的反思》。正是法国大革命将民族和现代民族主义的思想输出到了欧洲，甚至可以说是全世界。而且它的肖像学，汤姆，我们至今仍非常熟悉。
I mean, obviously it gave France its national anthem. It gave it its flag, the tricolour flag. But the idea of left and right comes from the French Revolution, from where people sat. In the National Assembly, right, isn't it? Exactly. And when you think about all the great writing that's been done on it, even just in English, Dickens' A Tale of Two Cities,
我的意思是，显然它给了法国国歌。它给了法国国旗，即三色旗。但左右翼的概念来自法国大革命，来自人们的座位。在国民议会里，对吧？正是如此。当你想到所有关于它的伟大著作时，即使只是用英语写的，狄更斯的《双城记》，
one of the most influential books on our perception of history that has ever been written. Dickens' influence by Carlyle and his great history of the revolution. And of all the history books that have been written in our lifetimes, one of the most influential on the way people write history, I think, is Simon Sharma's book Citizens. Some listeners may not agree with Sharma's take on the revolution. His take is actually not dissimilar from Margaret Thatcher's because he very much emphasises the violence and the costs of the revolution. But the way he did it, the emphasis on narrative and his ability to take unexpected aspects
这是有史以来对我们历史认知影响最大的书籍之一。狄更斯受到卡莱尔及其伟大的革命史的影响。在我们有生之年写下的所有历史书中，我认为对人们书写历史方式影响最大的一本是西蒙·沙玛的《公民》。一些听众可能不同意沙玛对革命的看法。他的看法实际上与玛格丽特·撒切尔的并不相似，因为他非常强调革命的暴力和代价。但他所采用的方式，对叙事的强调，以及他能够选取意想不到的方面，
and to take byroads and to make them so richly fascinating and colourful. Well, that's his great genius as a writer, isn't it? I mean, it's a reflection of the inherent drama and the scale and the sweep of the French Revolution that has inspired such great writers. So there's Hilary Mantel as well. You know, her first great historical novel that's about the French Revolution. Yeah. Actually, it's for me, her best book. Well, one of her, certainly her best historical book. Yeah. And what makes it so interesting is not just the high drama, but obviously the questions. Why did it all happen? And even more than that,
并走上旁路，使它们变得如此引人入胜且丰富多彩。嗯，这就是他作为作家的伟大天赋，不是吗？我的意思是，这反映了法国大革命内在的戏剧性、规模和广度，正是这些激发了如此多伟大的作家。所以还有希拉里·曼特尔。你知道，她第一部伟大的历史小说就是关于法国大革命的。是的。实际上，对我来说，这是她最好的书。嗯，肯定是她最好的历史书之一。是的。而让它如此有趣的原因不仅是高潮迭起的戏剧性，显然还有那些问题。这一切为什么会发生？甚至更重要的是，
what does it mean? Well, Dominic, we've answered that. It's because of the diamond necklace scandal. Right. So we can stop right now. We've solved it. So what I thought we'd do today is we'd get into the build-up to the revolution, the causes of the revolution. See, I don't think the French Revolution began in July 1789 with the stormy of the Bastille. No, we know when it began. It began in the 11th century, Dominic, but we'll be coming to that. Right, very good. So to be very, very simplistic for a second,
它意味着什么？嗯，多米尼克，我们已经回答了。是因为钻石项链丑闻。对。所以我们现在可以停下来了。我们已经解决了。所以我今天想做的是，我们要深入探讨革命的酝酿过程，革命的原因。你看，我不认为法国大革命始于 1789 年 7 月巴士底狱的暴动。不，我们知道它始于何时。它始于 11 世纪，多米尼克，但我们稍后会谈到这一点。对，非常好。所以，为了简单一点，
if people are only going to listen to six minutes of this podcast and they want to know why the French Revolution happened, I think there are three ingredients. One is there is a financial and a high political crisis. Effectively, France is running out of money. Number two, a social crisis. There's horrendous weather, freak weather. There's famine.
如果人们只打算听这个播客六分钟，并且想知道为什么会发生法国大革命，我认为有三个要素。一是存在财政和高层政治危机。实际上，法国没钱了。第二，社会危机。天气极其恶劣，反常的天气。发生了饥荒。
There is kind of mass hunger in France. So contingency then. So contingency. And then the third thing, which is much more deterministic, is a kind of cultural moment. And I know you'll be talking about this in a subsequent episode. An obsession with progress, with purity, and above all, with virtue. And an idea that you can turn the world off and back on again, and start again with a clean slate, and forget about the record of history. And I think it is the combination of those three things
法国出现了某种大规模的饥饿。所以是偶然性。所以是偶然性。第三点，也是更具决定性的一点，是一种文化时刻。我知道你会在后续剧集中谈到这一点。对进步、纯洁，尤其是对美德的痴迷。以及一种认为你可以关闭世界再重新启动，从一张白纸开始，忘记历史记录的想法。我认为正是这三者的结合，
that makes it different from the two obvious antecedents, which Mrs. Thatcher mentioned, the Glorious Revolution in Britain in 1688-89, and then, of course, the revolution in the American colonies. Although that is important, I think. It is important, but this is qualitatively different. Absolutely. So the question is, why did those three things, how and why did they come together? And for many years, historians looked for big, overarching ideological explanations.
使它不同于撒切尔夫人提到的两个明显的前身，即 1688-89 年英国的光荣革命，当然还有美国殖民地的革命。尽管这很重要，我认为。这很重要，但这是性质上的不同。绝对是。所以问题是，为什么这三件事，它们是如何以及为什么结合在一起的？多年来，历史学家一直在寻找宏大的、总括性的意识形态解释。
But then, really, especially from the 1980s onwards, and thanks partly to people like Sharma or Robert Danton, another brilliant historian, American historian who's written about this period, historians started to use the French Revolution as the subject to reinvigorate the idea of narrative, to say, actually, events really matter. And the chronology, the series, the chain is enormously important. And people who've listened to our series on the road to the First World War will recognize the parallels with that. Yeah, I was thinking about that. The replacement of the broad sweeping explanations that are couched in terms of ideology or whatever. Yeah, exactly. Or kind of broad Marxist trends and replacing it with the idea of events mattering.
但后来，特别是从 20 世纪 80 年代开始，多亏了像沙玛或罗伯特·达恩顿（另一位写过这一时期的杰出美国历史学家）这样的人，历史学家开始利用法国大革命作为重振叙事理念的主题，去说，实际上，事件真的很重要。而且时间顺序、系列、链条非常重要。听过我们关于第一次世界大战之路系列节目的听众会认出其中的相似之处。是的，我当时就在想这个。用事件重要性的理念取代那些用意识形态等术语包装的宏大解释。是的，正是如此。或者某种广泛的马克思主义趋势，并用事件重要性的理念取而代之。
Contingency mattering. Exactly. Exactly. But you ended last time, you did that brilliant episode about the diamond necklace scandal and your point that all the discussion about Marie Antoinette, the sort of the semi-pornographic, or I mean, the literary pornographic pamphlets and the abuse of her, that it reflected an idea that if, as it were, the body of the queen or the king were diseased, that reflected a disease in the body politic. And that's how we ended. But we didn't say why the body politic was diseased. So what is wrong with France? I guess that is the question. And to start with, let's kick off with
偶然性的重要性。正是如此。正是如此。但你上次结束时，你做了那期关于钻石项链丑闻的精彩节目，你的观点是，所有关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的讨论，那种半色情的，或者说文学色情的小册子以及对她的辱骂，反映了一种观点，即如果女王或国王的身体患病，那反映了政治体患病。这就是我们结束的地方。但我们没有说为什么政治体患病。所以法国出了什么问题？我想这就是问题所在。首先，让我们从
the man that you introduced us to, Louis XVI. So you described him as, I think very reasonably, a kind of reasonably likable, but ultimately slightly inconsequential man, mild, affable. He loves his locks, going hunting, but not a man it is easy to hate. So you look at Louis XVI and you don't see a man who millions of people would want to see dragged to the guillotine. He's not a monster. No, he's not a monster at all. He became king when he was 19 years old in 1774. And actually, you might say a young man, but actually that's quite old for a French king. Yeah, because usually they're toddlers, aren't they, when they come to the throne? His grandfather, Louis XV, had been five.
你向我们介绍的那个人开始，路易十六。所以你描述他，我认为非常合理，是一个相当讨人喜欢，但最终有点无关紧要的人，温和、和蔼。他喜欢他的锁具，喜欢打猎，但不是一个容易让人憎恨的人。所以你看着路易十六，你不会看到一个数百万人想看到他被拖上断头台的人。他不是个怪物。不，他根本不是个怪物。他 1774 年 19 岁时成为国王。实际上，你可能会说他是个年轻人，但对于法国国王来说，这其实已经相当老了。是的，因为他们通常在蹒跚学步时就登基了，不是吗？他的祖父路易十五登基时才五岁。
His predecessor, Louis XIV, had been four when he became king. So actually, Louis is not badly placed, and he's been prepared for it. His kingdom, as we discussed before, the biggest kingdom in continental Europe, 28 million people, the world's second largest economic power, really, after Britain, the only European country that has both the serious navy and a serious army. Britain, for example, only really has a navy. Paris, very different from today's Paris. So it's the second biggest city in Europe after London, but it's a city. It's not the kind of grand city of avenues and boulevards. It's a city of slums, but also, you know, it's typically the urban poor and prostitutes and
他的前任路易十四登基时才四岁。所以实际上，路易的处境并不坏，而且他为此做好了准备。他的王国，正如我们之前讨论过的，是欧洲大陆最大的王国，拥有 2800 万人口，实际上是继英国之后世界第二大经济强国，是唯一一个既有强大海军又有强大陆军的欧洲国家。例如，英国实际上只有海军。巴黎，与今天的巴黎截然不同。它是继伦敦之后欧洲第二大城市，但它是一个城市。它不是那种拥有大道和林荫大道的宏伟城市。它是一个贫民窟城市，但也，你知道，它通常是城市贫民和妓女以及
criminals, but also a city of coffee houses and books and ideas and newspapers and theatres and all these kinds of things. And then beyond it, you have the other big cities of France also doing very well. So France is unusual in having so many provincial centres, prosperous provincial centres, like Bordeaux and Lyon and stuff. And then beyond that, eight out of 10 French people work on the land. In La France Profonde, they are peasants by and large. So France is much, much more agricultural than Britain is. It is, and also much more kind of regionally distinct. Places like Brittany are very distinctive and you saw that when we were talking about the Cardinal
罪犯的聚集地，但也是一个咖啡馆、书籍、思想、报纸和剧院以及所有这些东西的城市。而在它之外，你还有法国其他的大城市，它们也发展得很好。所以法国不同寻常之处在于拥有如此多的省会中心，繁荣的省会中心，比如波尔多和里昂等等。而在那之外，十分之八的法国人在土地上工作。在“深层法国”（La France Profonde），他们基本上是农民。所以法国比英国农业化程度高得多。确实，而且在区域上也更具独特性。像布列塔尼这样的地方非常有特色，当我们谈论罗昂枢机时，你看到了这一点，
de Rohan, that he has a sense of his distinctiveness because he is Breton. Yeah, absolutely. The funny thing about Louis XVI, Louis XVI would not have been able to understand most of his subjects because they wouldn't have spoken what he would recognize as French. They would have spoken dialects of French, or they'd have spoken Flemish, or Occitan, or Breton, or German, all of these kinds of things. So Louis has been brought up to be king. We think of him as an absolute monarch. And he had copied out as a teenager a text to tell him
他有一种独特感，因为他是布列塔尼人。是的，绝对。关于路易十六有趣的一点是，路易十六无法理解他的大多数臣民，因为他们说的不是他所认知的法语。他们说的是法语方言，或者他们说的是弗拉芒语、奥克语、布列塔尼语或德语，所有这些东西。所以路易从小就被培养成国王。我们认为他是绝对君主。他在十几岁时抄写过一段文字来告诉他，
that French kings had received from God himself the greatest and most absolute power over other men that has ever been entrusted to one man. But that absolute power is very tightly circumscribed. So first of all, he relies on lots of other people. He relies on judges and nobles and officials. He's got his entendants, they're called the royal officials that they send out to the kingdom. If he loses their support, that's very bad for him.
法国国王从上帝本人那里获得了有史以来委托给一个人的、对其他人最伟大、最绝对的权力。但那种绝对权力受到非常严格的限制。首先，他依赖许多其他人。他依赖法官、贵族和官员。他有他的“监督官”（intendants），那是他们派往王国的皇家官员。如果他失去了他们的支持，那对他来说非常糟糕。
He needs them. Because he does have a famous exchange, doesn't he? Is it 1787? Where he basically, someone in the parliament was saying, this is illegal. Yeah. And Louis famously says, it's legal because I say it is. Yeah. But that's a mark of weakness, isn't it? Rather than a strength that he has to say that. Right. Because France does have other institutions and constitutional conventions, and they are so complicated that nobody really understands them. So his grandfather, Louis XV, in the 1750s, had said, you know, France is such a kind of multi-layered, complicated machine.
他需要他们。因为他确实有过一次著名的交流，不是吗？是 1787 年吗？当时他基本上，议会里的某个人说，这是非法的。是的。路易名言道，这是合法的，因为我说它是。是的。但这是一种软弱的标志，不是吗？而不是一种力量，因为他必须这么说。对。因为法国确实有其他机构和宪法惯例，而且它们太复杂了，没人真正理解它们。所以他的祖父路易十五在 18 世纪 50 年代曾说，你知道，法国是一个多层次、复杂的机器。
I'd like to get all this written down on paper so I can make sense of it. And he'd commissioned constitutional scholars to make a compilation of documents. And they came back to him eventually and they just said, we're going to give up, it's not possible. It's much too complicated because it's a bit like britain it is a massive patchwork of conventions and customs and laws and precedents and things yeah precedents you compared it to a machine and we talked about how louis xvi is a great one for tinkering in a workshop do you think that this is a frustration to him, that he, as someone who obviously likes contraptions and working out how things function, that the state kind of defies his ability to do that?
我想把这一切写在纸上，这样我才能理清头绪。他委托宪法学者汇编文件。他们最终回到他身边，只是说，我们要放弃了，这不可能。它太复杂了，因为它有点像英国，是一个由惯例、习俗、法律和先例组成的巨大拼凑物。是的，先例。你把它比作一台机器，我们谈到了路易十六是如何喜欢在车间里修修补补的，你认为这对他来说是一种挫败感吗？作为一个显然喜欢机械装置并研究事物如何运作的人，国家在某种程度上违背了他这样做的能力？
I think absolutely. Because I think Louis, like other people of his generation, is a product of the mid-18th century. He comes from a different world from Louis XIV. He's an enlightenment man to some degree. And that doesn't mean he's sitting there reading Voltaire, but it means he's in that context. Things can be solved. Things can be sorted. Yeah. The historian Jeremy Popkin, who wrote a very good general history of the French Revolution called A New World Begins, he says in that, Louis had been brought up to respect reason, as so many people were. He likes the idea of solving problems, Tom, that there is a logical, rational answer to things. He's also been brought up, by the way, to respect what he sees as the
我认为绝对是。因为我认为路易和他那一代的其他人一样，是 18 世纪中叶的产物。他来自一个与路易十四不同的世界。他在某种程度上是一个启蒙运动者。这并不意味着他坐在那里读伏尔泰，但意味着他处于那种背景下。事情是可以解决的。事情是可以理顺的。是的。写过一本非常好的法国大革命通史《新世界开始》的历史学家杰里米·波普金在书中说，路易从小就被培养去尊重理性，就像许多人一样。他喜欢解决问题的想法，汤姆，即事物有一个合乎逻辑、理性的答案。顺便说一句，他也被培养去尊重他所看到的
rights of his citizens. I know you're going to be talking a lot about rights in a subsequent episode. And Louis had written down in his kind of exercise book as a boy that the rights of his citizens were life, honour, liberty, and property. Not so dissimilar from the language of the American tax dodgers, Tom. So his regime, the regime that he inherits, the ancien regime, as people say, the old regime. In your sort of Charles Dickens, Taylor Tussauds version of the French Revolution, it's corrupt and cruel, isn't it? There's Marquesses kind of running over paupers in their carriages. Exactly, all of that stuff.
他公民的权利。我知道你会在后续剧集中谈论很多关于权利的问题。路易小时候在练习本上写道，他公民的权利是生命、荣誉、自由和财产。与那些美国逃税者的语言没什么两样，汤姆。所以他的政权，他继承的政权，人们所说的“旧制度”（ancien regime）。在你那种查尔斯·狄更斯的《双城记》版本的法国大革命中，它是腐败和残酷的，不是吗？有侯爵在马车里碾压穷人。正是如此，所有这些东西。
And very antiquated and reactionary. In reality, that regime is very, very modern and is changing all the time. Nobody says we are living in the ancien regime, we're living in the old regime. They think they're living in an age of enormous change and modernity. And we mentioned already Simon Schama.
而且非常陈旧和反动。实际上，那个政权非常、非常现代，而且一直在变化。没有人说我们生活在旧制度中，我们生活在旧制度中。他们认为他们生活在一个巨大变革和现代性的时代。我们已经提到了西蒙·沙玛。
In his book, Citizens, he's brilliant at bringing all this out. And he says, you know, wherever you look as a historian, there are signs of great excitement and dynamism and energy. So he mentions, you know, French trade, French industry. It's the home of chemistry, of maths. Lavoisier, who will end up losing his head, won't he, in the revolution? Exactly. The great chemist. Both Sharma and Robert Danton in their books about this emphasize hot air balloons. Ballooning is the AI of the day. It's something that people are
在他的书《公民》中，他非常擅长把这一切展现出来。他说，你知道，作为历史学家，无论你往哪里看，都有巨大的兴奋、活力和能量的迹象。所以他提到了，你知道，法国贸易、法国工业。它是化学、数学的家园。拉瓦锡，他最终会在革命中丢掉脑袋，不是吗？正是如此。伟大的化学家。沙玛和罗伯特·达恩顿在他们关于这一时期的书中都强调了热气球。气球飞行是那个时代的 AI。它是人们正在
talking about. They don't know what world it will bring. It's tremendously exciting. The first flight was from the Bois de Boulogne in 1783. And people would say, Robert D'Arnton quotes some periodicals, we live in the century of inventions. We're surrounded by miracles. Genius is everywhere, conquering nature and the elements. And that's very enlightenment, isn't it? It's totally enlightenment. So Benjamin Franklin is a great hero in Paris, and he's a great one for these kind of experiments. Absolutely, yeah. Because, of course, the whole American Republic is an experiment, isn't it? So America comes to be identified both with nature and the kind of beauties and simplicity of nature, but also with this idea of kind of progress, of modernity. And to what extent is the existence of the American Republic a kind of standing encouragement to people in France to think, yeah, we could rebuild in that
谈论的东西。他们不知道它会带来什么世界。这非常令人兴奋。第一次飞行是在 1783 年从布洛涅森林起飞的。人们会说，罗伯特·达恩顿引用了一些期刊的话，我们生活在发明的世纪。我们被奇迹包围。天才无处不在，征服自然和元素。这非常启蒙，不是吗？这完全是启蒙。所以本杰明·富兰克林在巴黎是一位伟大的英雄，他非常热衷于这类实验。绝对是，是的。因为，当然，整个美国共和国就是一个实验，不是吗？所以美国既被认同为自然，被认同为自然的美丽和纯朴，也被认同为这种进步、现代性的理念。美国共和国的存在在多大程度上是对法国人民的一种持续鼓励，让他们认为，是的，我们可以以那种方式重建？
way? It's a good question. I think people are fascinated by the American experiment. They're curious to see how it works out. People like Benjamin Franklin are very popular in France. But that said, if America didn't exist, the French Revolution would still have happened. Would still have happened, sure. Yeah. So I don't think it's a direct inspiration, but I think there's a commonality of language between the French and American revolutions. And just going on from that, the crown support for the American Revolution obviously will play a key part in its ultimate bankruptcy. But is there also a sense that the fact that a monarch
这是一个好问题。我认为人们对美国实验很着迷。他们很好奇想看看它会如何发展。像本杰明·富兰克林这样的人在法国非常受欢迎。但话虽如此，如果美国不存在，法国大革命依然会发生。依然会发生，当然。是的。所以我认为它不是直接的灵感来源，但我认为法国大革命和美国革命之间有一种共同的语言。顺便说一句，王室对美国革命的支持显然将在其最终破产中发挥关键作用。但有没有一种感觉，即一个君主
is going to the assistance of rebels against another monarch, an example of someone sitting on a tree, sitting on a branch, and sawing off the branch? Yeah, I think it is. I mean, there are people in the French regime who are very nervous about the idea of doing this. For that reason? Yeah.
去援助反抗另一个君主的叛军，是一个人坐在树上，坐在树枝上，然后锯掉树枝的例子？是的，我认为是。我的意思是，法国政权中有人对这样做感到非常紧张。因为那个原因？是的。
Well, they're more worried about the finances. But I just wondered whether there was a kind of,, well, they're more worried about the finances. But I just wondered whether there was a kind of, you know, an ideological anxiety about it as well. Because Louis XVI seems not particularly to have been worried about that. I don't think they're thinking about the American Republic so closely as that, to be honest with you. Right. I think they're more interested in giving Britain a bloody nose.
嗯，他们更担心财政问题。但我只是想知道是否有一种……嗯，他们更担心财政问题。但我只是想知道是否有一种，你知道，关于它的意识形态焦虑。因为路易十六似乎并没有特别担心这一点。老实说，我不认为他们对美国共和国的思考有那么深入。对。我认为他们更感兴趣的是给英国一点颜色看看。
Anyway, so all this excitement about change means you have two things. You have a trend of sense of possibility on the one hand. We can do anything. We can conquer nature. So what can't we do? And then the other hand, of course, there are always people who lose out from change. So in this, just to give you a small example, if you're a weaver or an artisan or something, there are new businesses, new industrialized businesses coming up that may put you out of work. And so you would like to blame somebody. And we'll come to that later on. As part of that modernity, I think you also get a new political culture, especially in Paris. This is not created by the French Revolution.
总之，所有这些关于变革的兴奋意味着你有两件事。一方面，你有一种可能性的趋势。我们可以做任何事。我们可以征服自然。那么我们有什么做不到的呢？另一方面，当然，总有人在变革中受损。所以，举个小例子，如果你是一个织布工或工匠什么的，有新的企业，新的工业化企业出现，可能会让你失业。所以你会想责怪某人。我们稍后会谈到这一点。作为现代性的一部分，我认为你还得到了一种新的政治文化，特别是在巴黎。这不是法国大革命创造的。
It creates the revolution. Right, because we were talking about that in the context of the pornographic abuse of Marie Antoinette. Exactly. Robert Danton's book, The Revolutionary Temper, is absolutely wonderful on all this. On the coffee houses, on people swapping ideas, people would read pamphlets out on street corners, people would gather to listen to it. There's a new term which we're very familiar with, created in 1750 to describe this, opinion publique, public opinion. That phrase was not used before because it didn't really exist in the same way. So there's that. But also I think there is a really important thing,
它创造了革命。对，因为我们在玛丽·安托瓦内特色情辱骂的背景下谈论过这一点。正是如此。罗伯特·达恩顿的书《革命气质》在所有这些方面都非常精彩。关于咖啡馆，关于人们交换思想，人们会在街角朗读小册子，人们会聚集在一起听。有一个我们非常熟悉的新术语，在 1750 年创造出来描述这个，即“公众舆论”（opinion publique）。那个短语之前没有被使用，因为它并没有以同样的方式真正存在。所以有这一点。但我认为还有一件非常重要的事情，
which is a new language that people use to discuss politics. So we were saying that Louis, you talked about him and the locks, the idea of tinkering and the world being a machine and improving it. And that's very much a product of the age of reason. But actually, when he becomes king and he's 19 years old, there is a generation emerging, this kind of generation below him, who are much more romantic. They are the people who are loving Rousseau, Jean-Jacques Rousseau. Well, but not entirely, because Marie Antoinette,
那就是人们用来讨论政治的新语言。所以我们说路易，你谈到了他和锁具，修修补补的想法，世界是一台机器并改进它。这非常是理性时代的产物。但实际上，当他 19 岁成为国王时，出现了一代人，他下面这一代人，他们更浪漫。他们是热爱卢梭、让-雅克·卢梭的人。嗯，但不完全是，因为玛丽·安托瓦内特，
who is his generation, I mean, she's part of that. I mean, she is the great embodiment of that in a way. It's definitely younger people who embrace that, but of course it percolates out. So Marie Antoinette is absolutely a classic example of somebody who absorbs this cult of sensibility, nature, simplicity, all of these things, intense feeling, tenderness, friendship,
她是这一代人，我的意思是，她是其中的一部分。我的意思是，她在某种程度上是这一点的伟大化身。肯定是年轻人拥抱了这一点，但当然它也渗透出去了。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特绝对是一个吸收了这种感性、自然、纯朴、所有这些东西、强烈情感、温柔、友谊、
family. And also the idea that if you obey the impulses of your emotions, that will lead you to truth. So it's kind of bizarre, isn't it? That simultaneously it's an age of reason, but it's also an age of intense feeling. So those things are in tension. Well, there is a tension there, but there seems to be an assumption that there isn't. Well, I think there was a slight generational issue. So I think if you were born in 1740, let's say, you grow up in an age that is polite, witty, ironic, sceptical. Voltaire. Voltaire is very sceptical. They love poking fun. There's always a kind of wry smile at the corner of your mouth, that kind of attitude.
家庭崇拜的人的典型例子。还有一种想法，如果你顺从情感的冲动，那将引导你走向真理。所以这很奇怪，不是吗？它既是一个理性时代，同时也是一个强烈情感的时代。所以这些事物处于紧张状态。嗯，那里确实存在一种紧张关系，但似乎有一种假设认为没有。嗯，我认为有一点代际问题。所以我想如果你出生在 1740 年，比如说，你在一个礼貌、机智、讽刺、怀疑的时代长大。伏尔泰。伏尔泰非常怀疑。他们喜欢开玩笑。你的嘴角总是带着一种苦笑，那种态度。
They're basically quite British. And I think if you are a generation later, let's say you're born in 1760, then that scepticism and stuff, you find that a bit desiccated maybe. It leaves you cold. What you're all about is your heart. Living your truth, Tom.
他们基本上很像英国人。我想如果你是下一代，比如说你出生在 1760 年，那么那种怀疑主义什么的，你可能会觉得有点枯燥。它让你感到冷漠。你所关心的就是你的心。活出你的真理，汤姆。
Living your truth, yes. And tears, crying, is really important to these people and is important in the revolution. Tears are seen as a sign of authenticity and honesty. So people are always breaking down in tears in the revolutionary story. And the idea that underpins all of this is the idea of virtue. And I was thinking when I was writing the notes, how virtue in the French Revolution is the diversity of its day. In other words, it is an abstract noun that if you have any decency as a person at all, you're in favour of it. And if you start to poke fun at it or to say, well, I just think it's all overblown. It's the emperor's new clothes. I don't really agree with it.
活出你的真理，是的。眼泪，哭泣，对这些人来说非常重要，在革命中也很重要。眼泪被视为真实和诚实的标志。所以人们在革命故事中总是泪流满面。支撑这一切的理念是美德的理念。我在写笔记时在想，美德在法国大革命中是如何成为那个时代的“多样性”的。换句话说，它是一个抽象名词，如果你作为一个人的话有任何体面，你就会支持它。如果你开始嘲笑它，或者说，嗯，我只是觉得它被夸大了。这是皇帝的新衣。我不太同意它。
People say, you're not just old, you're evil. You say virtue. I mean, you might more properly say virtus, is the latin word from which the french word comes and actually has the sense of of manliness right as well and i think one of the dimensions of the french revolution which we will be exploring over the course of this series and the subsequent series on it is the way in which actually the egalite bros are quite sexist yeah of course i mean it is a very very chauvinist movement, I think, the French Revolution. Yeah, I think so. So the man who embodies all this more than anybody else, by the way, I think is Maximilien Robespierre.
人们会说，你不仅老，而且邪恶。你说美德。我的意思是，你更恰当地说“virtus”，这是法语单词来源的拉丁词，实际上也有男子气概的意思，对吧？而且我认为法国大革命的一个维度，我们将在这个系列和后续系列中探讨，就是实际上“平等兄弟”相当性别歧视的方式。是的，当然，我的意思是，我认为法国大革命是一个非常、非常沙文主义的运动。是的，我想是这样。所以，顺便说一句，我认为比任何人都更能体现这一切的人是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。
And we'll come to him later on. He absolutely drinks deeply of all this stuff. So it's a very politicized world and very passionate. But it is also, I think it's worth emphasizing, even before the revolution, a violent world. In Citizens, Simon Sharma famously wrote that violence was not just a byproduct of politics, but violence was the revolution itself. And I think he's right, but I think it's also worth emphasizing that France was already quite violent. So any history of 18th century France is punctuated by riots, lynchings, looting, people being publicly beheaded, prisoners being broken on the wheel, troops firing into crowds. So in other words, when the revolution starts, and it doesn't start with one thing, it starts with a succession of things, a lot of these things have already happened before.
我们稍后会谈到他。他绝对深深地沉浸在所有这些东西中。所以这是一个非常政治化的世界，非常充满激情。但我认为，值得强调的是，即使在革命之前，这也是一个暴力的世界。在《公民》中，西蒙·沙玛名言道，暴力不仅是政治的副产品，暴力本身就是革命。我认为他是对的，但我认为也值得强调的是，法国本身就已经相当暴力了。所以任何 18 世纪法国的历史都充斥着骚乱、私刑、抢劫、人们被公开斩首、囚犯被车轮刑处死、军队向人群开火。所以换句话说，当革命开始时，它不是始于一件事，它始于一系列事情，很多这些事情之前就已经发生过了。
They're not novelties. The revolution is not a storm breaking from an otherwise placid beautiful blue sky it's a one storm cloud among many tom yeah but you mentioned well we talked about tax and finance so money is at the absolute center of it and we should get into some of the money follow the money follow the money exactly we should follow the money so all early modern monarchies suffered massive money problems. I mean, it's the story of the English Civil War. It's the story of the American Revolution. Monarchies trying to raise more funds. And the reason they're doing that is because they're living in a new age with antiquated systems. There's been a military revolution. So they are funding bigger navies and bigger armies than ever before.
它们不是新鲜事。革命不是从原本平静美丽的蓝天中爆发的一场风暴，它是众多风暴云中的一朵，汤姆。是的，但你提到了，嗯，我们谈到了税收和财政，所以金钱处于绝对中心，我们应该深入探讨一些金钱问题。跟着钱走，跟着钱走，正是如此。我们应该跟着钱走。所以所有早期现代君主制都遭受了巨大的金钱问题。我的意思是，这是英国内战的故事。这是美国革命的故事。君主们试图筹集更多资金。他们这样做是因为他们生活在一个拥有陈旧系统的新时代。发生了一场军事革命。所以他们资助了比以往任何时候都更庞大的海军和陆军。
But also they're doing it on a global scale, which they weren't doing 200 years earlier. You know, Britain, France, they have to maintain fleets all over the planet. And for France, the fact that Britain has emerged as a rival power and in a larger economy, I mean, is really unsettling because France has not had to face that before. France has always been the largest power. It has. Economically speaking. And so that imposes massive strains, doesn't it? Massive.
但他们也在全球范围内这样做，这是他们 200 年前没有做的。你知道，英国、法国，他们必须在地球各地维持舰队。对于法国来说，英国作为一个竞争对手和更大的经济体出现，我的意思是，这真的令人不安，因为法国以前不必面对这种情况。法国一直是最大的强国。确实。从经济上讲。所以这施加了巨大的压力，不是吗？巨大。
And you were talking about the Navy. The Royal Navy is the key to British power. And so the French have to have a Navy. But as you say, I mean, it's just unbelievable strain. It is. So France has been running up massive debts since the 1720s and doesn't have a national bank. Britain has a national bank, but France, for various reasons, doesn't. Oh, and France had had a kind of traumatic experience with a slightly dodgy Scottish financier, hadn't it? John Law.
你刚才谈到了海军。皇家海军是英国力量的关键。所以法国必须拥有一支海军。但正如你所说，我的意思是，这简直是难以置信的压力。确实。所以法国自 18 世纪 20 年代以来一直在背负巨额债务，而且没有国家银行。英国有国家银行，但法国由于各种原因没有。哦，而且法国曾有过一次与一位稍微有点狡猾的苏格兰金融家的创伤性经历，不是吗？约翰·劳。
Yeah. John Law. Exactly. The beginning of the 18th century. It's a kind of tulip mania bust. There'd been a massive stock market bust, and that basically turned them off finance. So they distrust the idea of a national bank. You know, that is when the word millionaire is coined, because so many people become so
是的。约翰·劳。正是如此。18 世纪初。这是一种郁金香狂热式的破产。发生了一次大规模的股市崩盘，这基本上让他们对金融失去了兴趣。所以他们不信任国家银行的想法。你知道，这就是“百万富翁”（millionaire）这个词被创造出来的时候，因为这么多人变得如此
rich and then they lose it all. Is that so? Interesting. By the 1760s, so even before the American War, France has already got very, very big debts. It's 2 billion livres in debt, and it's basically spending 60% of its budget servicing that debt, so on interest payments. And this is growing all the time. The interesting thing is that Britain's debt is three times greater, but Britain can always raise new taxes through the House of Commons.
富有，然后又失去了一切。是这样吗？有趣。到 18 世纪 60 年代，所以甚至在美国战争之前，法国就已经有了非常、非常大的债务。它背负着 20 亿里弗尔的债务，基本上将其预算的 60% 用于偿还债务，也就是利息支付。而且这一直在增长。有趣的是，英国的债务是其三倍，但英国总是可以通过下议院筹集新税。
The government needs no more money, the House of Commons votes for it, bang, job done. France can't do that. Not only does it not have a national bank, it doesn't have a regular elected assembly. People do remember that there was once a thing called the Estates General. It last met in 1614, 1615, and nobody can really remember what it was, how it was organised, who voted for it. Is the existence of the British Parliament that is able to raise money, is this something that in the build-up to the French Revolution, people are looking at enviously and saying, why don't we have a system like this? Yes. As we will see, loads of people basically want France to have a lot of the revolutionaries at the beginning, basically want to turn France into Britain. They want a more liberal economy and they want a representative institution or vote tax increases. And they think, bang, that'll magically fix all our problems.
政府不需要更多钱，下议院投票通过，砰，工作完成。法国做不到这一点。它不仅没有国家银行，也没有定期的民选议会。人们确实记得曾经有一种东西叫“三级会议”。它最后一次开会是在 1614 年、1615 年，没人真正记得它是什么，它是如何组织的，谁为它投票。英国议会能够筹集资金的存在，这是在法国大革命酝酿过程中，人们羡慕地看着并说，为什么我们没有这样的系统？是的。正如我们将看到的，很多人基本上希望法国拥有……革命初期的大多数革命者，基本上想把法国变成英国。他们想要一个更自由的经济，他们想要一个代表机构或投票增加税收。他们认为，砰，那会神奇地解决我们所有的问题。
And so that's the Estates General. Exactly. That's their dream. So France is raising tax through a lot of very strange, antiquated things. They've got a property tax that a lot of towns don't pay. They've got a very lucrative tax on salt. But again, that means there's loads of smuggling. And they have internal customs duties. You are a miller in Provence or something. You want to sell your grain in Paris. You have to pay multiple duties to get your grain from A to B. And that obviously is very bad for the internal economy if people are having to pay tax, basically when they step outside their own town to sell things.
所以这就是三级会议。正是如此。那是他们的梦想。所以法国通过许多非常奇怪、陈旧的东西来征税。他们有一种很多城镇不支付的财产税。他们有一种非常有利可图的盐税。但同样，这意味着有大量的走私。而且他们有内部关税。你是一个普罗旺斯的磨坊主什么的。你想在巴黎卖你的谷物。你必须支付多重关税才能把你的谷物从 A 运到 B。如果人们在离开自己的城镇去卖东西时基本上必须纳税，那显然对内部经济非常不利。
And the kind of thing that a workman in his workshop, like Louis XVI, would want to fix. Exactly. So here's the thing. Why don't they fix it? Louis, when he comes in at the age of 19, he's tempted by the idea of fixing it. But the issue is that whenever he comes up against opposition, he almost always backs down. So right at the beginning of his reign, he had a bloke called Thieu Gau, who was a liberal reformer. He was basically slightly Liz Truss. He wanted to go for growth, deregulate the economy, all of this kind of stuff. He liberalized bread prices. Of course, that meant the bread prices went up. There was lots of looting. And Louis eventually basically got rid of him, said, you're pushing too far, too fast.
而且像路易十六这样的工匠在车间里会想要修复的那种东西。正是如此。所以问题就在这里。为什么他们不修复它？路易，当他 19 岁时进来，他被修复它的想法所诱惑。但问题是，每当他遇到反对时，他几乎总是退缩。所以在他统治之初，他有一个叫蒂尔戈（Turgot）的人，他是一位自由派改革者。他基本上有点像利兹·特拉斯。他想追求增长，放松经济管制，所有这些东西。他自由化了面包价格。当然，这意味着面包价格上涨了。发生了大量的抢劫。路易最终基本上解雇了他，说，你推得太远、太快了。
So, Dominic, your case might be that the problem with Louis isn't that he is too despotic, but that he's not despotic enough. Well, do you know who he should have been, Tom? You did a very, very lovely version of her. If he'd been Margaret Thatcher, I mean, I say this not entirely frivolously. If he'd been a charismatic and sufficiently adept statesman, that he could take a bit of unpopularity and he could persuade the people he needed, and he could show concrete results, and he'd stuck to his guns, he might have been a much,
所以，多米尼克，你的观点可能是，路易的问题不是他太专制，而是他不够专制。嗯，你知道他应该成为谁吗，汤姆？你做了一个非常、非常可爱的她的版本。如果他是玛格丽特·撒切尔，我的意思是，我这么说并非完全轻浮。如果他是一位有魅力且足够精明的政治家，他可以承受一点不受欢迎，他可以劝说他需要的人，他可以展示具体的成果，并且他坚持自己的立场，他可能是一个更有效、
much more effective king of France. But as it is, what he will do is he will always gesture in the direction of change and then back down when he gets into trouble. So as Sharma says, and I quote, he wanted to be loved. And that is not an ideal thing for a king in a time of tremendous change and challenge. So in the next few years, the problem actually gets a lot worse. And it gets worse, as you said, because they join the American war. So Turgot's eventual successor, a Swiss banker called Necker, Jean-Jacques Necker. Great name. He says, go for that American war.
更有效的法国国王。但事实是，他总是做出变革的姿态，然后在遇到麻烦时退缩。所以正如沙玛所说，我引用一下，他想被爱。这对于一个处于巨大变革和挑战时代的国王来说，并不是一个理想的事情。所以在接下来的几年里，问题实际上变得严重多了。而且正如你所说，情况变得更糟，因为他们加入了美国战争。所以蒂尔戈的最终继任者，一位名叫内克尔（Necker）、让-雅克·内克的瑞士银行家。好名字。他说，去参加那场美国战争吧。
Let's help the rebels in the American colonies. And he organizes lots more short-term loans to pay for it. Now, it's a naval war, but as we know from the rest of history, nothing is more expensive than an 18th century top-notch navy. So they run up huge debts, one and a half billion livres, on top of their existing debts, 90% of which comes from loans. This will be a brilliant gamble, by the way,
让我们帮助美国殖民地的叛军。他组织了更多短期贷款来支付它。现在，这是一场海军战争，但正如我们从历史余味中所知，没有什么比 18 世纪顶尖海军更昂贵的了。所以他们背负了巨额债务，15 亿里弗尔，在他们现有的债务之上，其中 90% 来自贷款。顺便说一句，这将是一场精彩的赌博，
if you get the Caribbean. Because the Caribbean is so rich. Yeah, that's why they really have joined the war. They want to get Jamaica, places like that. But that requires them to inflict a defeat on Britain more total than the ultimate defeat is.
如果你得到了加勒比海。因为加勒比海太富有了。是的，这就是他们真正加入战争的原因。他们想要牙买加，像那样的地方。但这需要他们对英国造成比最终失败更彻底的失败。
So although the British lose 13 North American colonies, they keep lots of the rest of North America. They don't lose any of the Caribbean, which was their main priority. And so actually, the French have basically run up huge debts and they've got nothing to show for it. And Simon Sharma says, without much exaggeration, it can be said that it was the cost of the war that brought on the terminal crisis of the French monarchy. Should we get to the terminal crisis? Yes. So let's fast forward, just before we come to the break, let's fast forward three years to the year of the diamond necklace trial. So now we're in 1786. The finance minister now is a guy called Charles-Alexandre de Calonne. He's very rich. He's very urbane. He's very
所以尽管英国失去了13个北美殖民地，但他们仍保留了北美其余的大部分领土。他们没有失去任何加勒比地区的领土，而那才是他们的首要任务。事实上，法国基本上背负了巨额债务，却一无所获。西蒙·沙马（Simon Sharma）说，毫不夸张地说，正是战争的代价导致了法国君主制的终极危机。我们应该谈谈这个终极危机吗？是的。那么让我们快进一下，在休息之前，让我们快进三年，来到钻石项链案审判的那一年。现在是1786年。当时的财政大臣是一个叫夏尔-亚历山大·德·卡隆（Charles-Alexandre de Calonne）的人。他非常有钱，非常圆滑，非常
sort of witty. He's a stock market player and therefore everybody hates him for understandable reasons bankers and in august 1786 calon goes to see louis the 16th and he says i've got a bit of a bombshell for you um we are looking into the financial abyss he says our annual deficit every year is 80 million livres, and half of all our revenue is now being spent on paying the interest on our existing loans. And he says, what is worse, NECA's short-term loans that he took out to pay for the war in America are about to fall due, and we don't have any money to pay them back. And he says to Louis,
风趣幽默。他是个股市玩家，因此出于可以理解的原因，银行家们都讨厌他。1786年8月，卡隆去见路易十六，他说：“我有个重磅消息要告诉你，我们正处于金融深渊的边缘。”他说，我们每年的赤字是8000万利弗尔，而且我们现在一半的收入都花在支付现有贷款的利息上了。他说，更糟糕的是，内克（Necker）为支付美国战争费用而借的短期贷款即将到期，而我们根本没有钱偿还。他对路易说，
we have to totally reform the constitution. We just have to sort out this problem with the tax system once and for all and get new taxes because we can't rely on new loans to pay the old loans. So you may say, well, what is this problem? Why don't they just bring in new taxes? And the reason is France is a society based on the idea of hierarchy and privileges. So if you are a nobleman or a clergyman, you don't pay tax. And people don't think of that as a disgraceful exemption. They think that's the essence of our liberties. These are our God-given and our ancestral rights as Frenchmen.
我们必须彻底改革宪法。我们必须一劳永逸地解决税收制度的问题，并征收新税，因为我们不能再靠借新债来还旧债了。你可能会问，这个问题到底是什么？为什么他们不直接征收新税呢？原因在于，法国是一个基于等级和特权观念的社会。所以，如果你是贵族或神职人员，你就不纳税。人们并不认为这是一种可耻的豁免，他们认为这是我们自由的精髓。这是我们作为法国人与生俱来的、祖传的权利。
And it's a source of aspiration, isn't it? Yeah. For people, because it is possible to enter the clergy or to gain patents of nobility. So it's a kind of incentive
这是一种抱负的源泉，不是吗？是的。对人们来说，因为进入神职阶层或获得贵族封号是有可能的。所以这是一种激励，
to stick with the system. It is. And also people don't like the idea of a uniform system like a machine. They say that is what will destroy liberty. Liberty lies in difference and in quirks and eccentricities and traditions. And a government
让人坚持这个制度。确实。而且人们也不喜欢像机器一样统一的制度。他们说那会摧毁自由。自由存在于差异、怪癖和传统之中。而一个政府，
that tries to erase that and just to put the stamp of royal authority and say everybody must pay is a despotic government. And we don't want that. We want people to stand up for our traditions. And the people they want in particular are these institutions called the parlement. Now, confusingly, they're not parliaments. Right. So these are the ones that the parlement of Paris that the Cardinal de Roja opted to be tried by rather than the king in the previous episode. They're courts. They're high courts, basically. Yeah. And around them, so the parlement in Paris employs hundreds of people, clerks and stuff. It's got its own kind of quarter of the city. There's a whole kind of community of lawyers and notaries around it. It's culturally very meaningful. People invest it with a lot of significance. The parlements, these high courts, when the king
如果试图抹杀这些，仅仅盖上皇权的印章说每个人都必须纳税，那就是专制政府。我们不想要那样。我们希望人们捍卫我们的传统。他们特别希望捍卫的机构被称为“高等法院”（parlement）。现在，令人困惑的是，它们不是议会（parliament）。没错。所以这就是罗昂枢机主教（Cardinal de Rohan）在上集里选择接受审判而不是由国王审判的那个巴黎高等法院。它们是法院，基本上是高等法院。是的。围绕着它们，比如巴黎高等法院雇佣了数百人，包括书记员之类的。它有自己的一片城区。周围有一整群律师和公证人。它在文化上非常有意义。人们赋予了它很多重要性。这些高等法院，当国王
introduces an edict, they have to register it. And they have to say, yep, fine. It doesn't contravene the rights of French people that you as a king have sworn to uphold. And what's happened, there's a pattern that basically since the 1750s, Louis XV and Louis XVI have asked the parliament to register new taxes and the parliament has bitterly resisted. And they have said increasingly, the reason we're resisting the new taxes is because we're defending liberty against your despotism. We're defending the nation against your court in Versailles. We're defending the ancient French constitution against your suffocating, joyless absolutism. And does the physical separation of the king in Versailles from the Parlement, say in Paris,
颁布法令时，他们必须进行登记。他们必须说：“好的，没问题。”它没有违反你作为国王宣誓要维护的法国人民的权利。发生的情况是，自1750年代以来，路易十五和路易十六一直要求高等法院登记新税，而高等法院一直激烈抵制。他们越来越多地说，我们抵制新税的原因是我们正在捍卫自由，反对你们的专制。我们正在捍卫国家，反对你们在凡尔赛的宫廷。我们正在捍卫古老的法国宪法，反对你们令人窒息、毫无乐趣的绝对主义。那么，国王在凡尔赛与在巴黎的高等法院之间的物理隔离，
that presumably is enhancing that sense of separation between the monarchy and the sense the Parlement have that they are defending the people's rights. I think so, Tom. I think absolutely. I think it's a real problem actually for Louis XVI. Geography. The fact that Versailles is 12 miles from Paris. He never leaves Versailles or barely ever leaves Versailles. That 12 miles miles most ordinary people can't afford to take an expensive coach to Versailles so he's always slightly sealed off he's always in a bit of a bubble and there's a real resentment of that bubble it creates the idea of a corrupt out of touch court and you know you get the sense that Paris is this kind of place seething with political excitement and theatre and new
大概增强了君主制与高等法院认为他们是在捍卫人民权利的这种分离感吧？我想是的，汤姆。我绝对这么认为。我认为这对路易十六来说确实是个大问题。地理位置。凡尔赛距离巴黎12英里。他从不离开凡尔赛，或者几乎从不离开。那12英里，大多数普通人负担不起昂贵的马车去凡尔赛，所以他总是稍微与世隔绝，总是处于某种泡沫之中，而人们对这个泡沫有着真正的怨恨。它制造了一种腐败、脱离群众的宫廷印象，你知道，你会感觉到巴黎是一个充满政治兴奋、戏剧和新
ideas and newspapers. And Versailles is this sort of airless world of snobbery and ritual. And I think it's a really good point. I agree with you. I think it's a huge problem for Louis. So anyway, Calonne says to Louis, look, we've got this huge problem. The Parlement are never going to give us what we want. We have to bypass the parliament. We have to go over their heads. I'm going to call an assembly of the greatest men in the kingdom, the notables. If they agree with the idea of the new taxes, then maybe we can basically just ignore the parliament and do what we like. And this idea of an assembly of notables, this is again, something with the ancient president that is being taken out of the lumber box of antiquated traditions.
思想以及报纸的地方。而凡尔赛是一个充满势利和仪式的沉闷世界。我认为这是一个非常好的观点。我同意你的看法。我认为这对路易来说是个巨大的问题。总之，卡隆对路易说，看，我们有这个巨大的问题。高等法院永远不会给我们想要的。我们必须绕过高等法院。我们必须越过他们。我要召集王国里最伟大的人，即显贵会议（notables）。如果他们同意新税的想法，那么也许我们基本上可以无视高等法院，做我们想做的事。而这个显贵会议的想法，这又是一个有着古老先例的东西，正从陈旧传统的杂物箱里被拿出来。
Yeah, it is. Exactly. And Louis says to Calonne, I'm not sure about this. I mean, this is a very big step to try to bypass the institutions to get this money. And Calonne says, trust me, if you do this, you will go down in history as the man whose courage and foresight solved the financial problems of the French monarchy forever. And historian Jeremy Popkin has a very strong line after this in his book. He says, and so Louis XVI allowed Calonne to set in motion the series of events that would lead to the complete overthrow of his monarchy. Well, cliffhangers don't come more cliffhanging than that. Let's take a break and when we come back we will see
是的，确实如此。路易对卡隆说，我不确定这一点。我的意思是，试图绕过这些机构来筹集资金是一个非常大的举动。卡隆说，相信我，如果你这样做，你将作为那个以勇气和远见永远解决了法国君主制财政问题的人而载入史册。历史学家杰里米·波普金（Jeremy Popkin）在他的书中对此有一句非常有力的评价。他说，于是路易十六允许卡隆启动了一系列将导致他君主制彻底覆灭的事件。好吧，悬念没有比这更悬疑的了。让我们休息一下，回来后我们将看到
how the doom spiral gets set in train. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
毁灭的螺旋是如何开始的。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们会拉开帷幕，
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in Versailles,
带你了解娱乐业，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。就是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。我们现在在凡尔赛，
specifically in the Salle des Menus Plaisir. It is the 22nd of February 1787. And Dominic, this assembly of the notables has gathered. With what consequence? So basically, Calonne has brought together all the bigwigs in the kingdom, princes, archbishops, judges, dukes, all of these people. And he says he says to them okay here's my plan we're going to abolish all these mad tax privileges we're just going to have one tax on landed property and irrespective of your social status you'll have to pay so he is asking turkeys to vote for christmas basically he is but he's saying that this is in the interest of france come on we've got to do this we don't want to keep losing to the British.
具体是在“小乐事厅”（Salle des Menus Plaisirs）。现在是1787年2月22日。多米尼克，这个显贵会议已经召集完毕。结果如何？基本上，卡隆召集了王国里所有的权贵，王子、大主教、法官、公爵，所有这些人。他对他们说，好吧，这是我的计划：我们要废除所有这些疯狂的税收特权，我们只对土地财产征收一种税，无论你的社会地位如何，你都必须支付。所以他基本上是在要求火鸡投票支持圣诞节。他确实是，但他是在说这是为了法国的利益，拜托，我们必须这样做，我们不想一直输给英国人。
Number two, he says, we're going to lift some of these mad antiquated regulations. Let's have the same, you pay the same duty wherever you are in France. Let's have freer markets so people can sell across France. We can relax some of these rules. So we'll have more competition. We'll have more growth. And number three, he says, I know I'm asking a lot. So we're going to have elected local assemblies regular elected local assemblies and basically you the landowners the bigwigs will dominate them so you'll get your way your privileges will remain
第二点，他说，我们要取消一些疯狂的陈旧法规。让我们统一起来，你在法国任何地方支付的关税都一样。让我们拥有更自由的市场，这样人们就可以在法国各地进行销售。我们可以放宽一些规则。这样我们就会有更多的竞争，更多的增长。第三点，他说，我知道我要求很高。所以我们将建立民选的地方议会，定期选举的地方议会，基本上你们这些土地所有者、权贵们将主导它们，所以你们会如愿以偿，你们的特权将保持
intact it's a very very enlightened scheme it's a very mid-18th century scheme it's rational it's sensible it's rational. It's sensible. It's kind of, let's have a bit of uniformity and sort this thing out. So it's not going to work, in other words. Yeah. And the notables just hate it. They hate it because they don't like, obviously, paying the land tax. They don't like his plan for the assemblies because he says, well, obviously, you'd sit with the commons in your province together in one assembly.
不变。这是一个非常非常开明的方案，这是一个非常18世纪中叶的方案，它是理性的，它是明智的。它是理性的。它是明智的。它有点像，让我们统一一下，把这件事解决掉。换句话说，它行不通。是的。而显贵们就是讨厌它。他们讨厌它，因为显然他们不喜欢支付土地税。他们不喜欢他关于议会的计划，因为他说，好吧，显然，你们会在你们的省份里与平民坐在一起，组成一个议会。
They don't like that at all. They say the commons, which they call the third estate, they have to be separate. We're not sitting with those. Riffraff. Great unwashed. Yeah, riffraff. It's always the game that these different institutions play.
他们一点也不喜欢那样。他们说平民，也就是他们所说的“第三等级”，必须分开。我们不和那些人坐在一起。乌合之众。下层民众。是的，乌合之众。这些不同的机构玩的游戏总是这样。
To basically kick the tax increases down the road, they say, you'd have to call the estates general. I mean, no one really knows what that is, because they think it'll never happen, I suspect. They say, call the estates general to call the Estates General. I mean, no one really knows what that is, but they sort of, because they think it'll never happen, I suspect. They say, call the Estates General to approve the taxes. It's like the Aztecs bringing out the owl. It's the ultimate recourse. You know, you need more representation.
基本上是为了把增税的问题推迟，他们说，你必须召集“三级会议”（Estates General）。我的意思是，没人真正知道那是什么，因为我怀疑他们认为这永远不会发生。他们说，召集三级会议来批准税收。这就像阿兹特克人请出猫头鹰一样。这是最后的手段。你知道，你需要更多的代表权。
Basically, we don't want to carry the can for the tax increases. You have to get a bigger body to do it. Calon is really furious about this. And now he does something that is actually disastrous from the perspective of the French monarchy. He goes public. He seeks to rouse the people. He sends a pamphlet out to every priest in the city in Paris. And he says, you have to read this to your congregation, your Sunday sermons.
基本上，我们不想为增税背黑锅。你必须找一个更大的机构来做这件事。卡隆对此非常愤怒。现在他做了一件从法国君主制的角度来看实际上是灾难性的事情。他公开了。他试图唤起民众。他给巴黎市的每一位牧师寄去了一份小册子。他说，你必须在周日的布道中向你的会众宣读这个。
He has it reprinted in gazettes. He has it read out on street corners and read aloud to the crowds in Les Halles in the big markets. And this thing, he tells people, France is at a crossroads. Finances are in a total mess. Either we have total change or total collapse. And in this pamphlet, he uses a lot of the language that anticipates the revolution. So he's using terms like the national will, patriotism. He says, the privilege will be sacrificed. Yes, when justice requires it and need demands it, would it be better to tax again the
他把它印在公报上。他让人在街角宣读，并大声读给大市场（Les Halles）的人群听。在这份小册子里，他告诉人们，法国正处于十字路口。财政状况一团糟。要么我们彻底改变，要么彻底崩溃。在这份小册子里，他使用了许多预示革命的语言。所以他使用了诸如“国民意志”、“爱国主义”之类的词汇。他说，特权将被牺牲。是的，当正义需要它，需求要求它时，再次向那些
unprivileged, the people? And that kind of language, people haven't heard that from royal finance ministers before. He's anticipating a lot of the terms that will be used in the revolution. Now, when the heat comes out with all this, the notables go absolutely ballistic. You know, how dare you rouse the people against us? And so they complain to Louis about him. So they complain to Louis, and Louis, as is always the way, Louis sacks him. Sorry mate, you've got to go. People don't like it. The notables don't like it. The notables don't like it. As Sharma says
没有特权的人民征税会更好吗？那种语言，人们以前从未从皇家财政大臣那里听到过。他预示了许多将在革命中使用的术语。现在，当卡隆拿出这一切时，显贵们彻底炸锅了。你知道，你怎么敢煽动人民反对我们？于是他们向路易投诉他。所以他们向路易投诉，而路易，一如既往，路易解雇了他。抱歉伙计，你得走了。人们不喜欢它。显贵们不喜欢它。显贵们不喜欢它。正如沙马在
in Citizens, by taking his case to the public, Calon had made politics a matter of national attention. Once Pandora's box had been opened in this way, it proved impossible to close the lid. After Calon, anything was possible. We love a Pandora's box.
《公民》（Citizens）一书中所说，通过将他的案件诉诸公众，卡隆使政治成为了全国关注的焦点。一旦潘多拉魔盒以这种方式被打开，就不可能再盖上盖子了。在卡隆之后，一切皆有可能。我们喜欢潘多拉魔盒。
I like the fact that Sharma's gone for Pandora's box there. So the Pandora's box has been opened and the storm clouds of revolution are gathering. Definitely they are. So the debate has started, a public debate. People are talking about this in cafes, on street corners and things. And as amazing as it may sound to many listeners,
我喜欢沙马在那里用了潘多拉魔盒这个比喻。所以潘多拉魔盒已经被打开，革命的乌云正在聚集。它们绝对在聚集。所以辩论已经开始了，一场公开的辩论。人们在咖啡馆、街角等地谈论这件事。尽管这对许多听众来说听起来很不可思议，
most people take the notable side, the side of the very privileged people who don't want to pay more taxes. So Robert D'Ar side, the side of the very privileged people who don't want to pay more taxes. So Robert D'Arnton quotes journalists of the day, our notables, which were thought to be puppets or courtiers, are for the most part well-informed patriots who know the true interests of the nation. Because the one thing that people are really worried about is not the fact that nobles don't pay taxes, it is they have a dread of an overweening autocratic monarchy. The nobles are very good at posing as the defenders of the French people's liberties
大多数人站在显贵一边，站在那些不想多纳税的特权阶层一边。所以罗伯特·达恩顿（Robert Darnton）引用当时记者的话说，我们的显贵，那些被认为是傀儡或朝臣的人，大多是消息灵通的爱国者，他们知道国家的真正利益。因为人们真正担心的一件事不是贵族不纳税的事实，而是他们对傲慢的专制君主制的恐惧。贵族们非常擅长伪装成法国人民自由的捍卫者，
and people believe it. People are roused by it. But they're kind of riding a crocodile, right? They are. Oh, totally. Yeah. The notables are in for a shock. They're in for a shock.
而人们相信了这一点。人们因此被煽动起来。但他们有点像是在骑虎难下，对吧？他们是。哦，完全是。是的。显贵们要大吃一惊了。他们要大吃一惊了。
So now Louis has to find a new finance minister and he says, well, what I'll do is I'll get one of the notables to do it. I mean, that's quite a canny idea. He gets a guy who's the Archbishop of Toulouse, who'd been a very outspoken notable, who's called Étienne Charles de Lomény de Brienne. He's a magnificent figure, isn't he? Because he's one of those kind of classic late 18th century French bishops who don't
所以现在路易必须找到一位新的财政大臣，他说，好吧，我要做的是找一位显贵来担任。我的意思是，这真是一个精明的想法。他找了一个人，是图卢兹大主教，他曾是一位非常直言不讳的显贵，名叫艾蒂安·夏尔·德·洛梅尼·德·布里安（Étienne Charles de Loménie de Brienne）。他是一个了不起的人物，不是吗？因为他是那种典型的18世纪末法国主教，他们并不
really believe in God yeah exactly but that's the thing nonsense there was talk of making him
真正相信上帝，是的，完全正确，但这就是重点。胡说八道，当时有传言说要让他担任
Archbishop of Paris and Louis had apparently said surely as Archbishop he should believe in God shouldn't he
巴黎大主教，路易显然说过，作为大主教，他肯定应该相信上帝，不是吗？
isn't that a good idea and Brienne also entertainingly there's a lot of skin disease in this series there really is
这不是个好主意吗？而且布里安也很有趣，这个系列里有很多皮肤病，真的有，
isn't there so Brienne I read he suffered from a skin disease that left his face quote a mass of peeling scabs and tissue and yet he was thought of as a in this series. There really is, isn't there? So Brienne, I read, he suffered from a skin disease that left his face, quote, a mass of peeling scabs and tissue.
不是吗？所以布里安，我读到他患有一种皮肤病，导致他的脸“布满了脱皮的痂和组织”，然而他被认为是一个在这个系列里。真的有，不是吗？所以布里安，我读到他患有一种皮肤病，导致他的脸，引用原文，“布满了脱皮的痂和组织”。
And yet he was thought of as a personable and congenial man. So that says a lot for his personality. It does. Well, so we've had Louis XV who died with his face covered in pustules. And we're going to be meeting
然而他被认为是一个风度翩翩、和蔼可亲的人。所以这说明了他的个性。确实。好吧，我们有路易十五，他死时脸上布满了脓疱。我们将要见到
Marat, aren't we? Yeah. And well, Mirabeau, the ugliest man in France. Mirabeau, yes. Yes, his face. Well, yes. So lots of victims
马拉（Marat），不是吗？是的。还有米拉波（Mirabeau），法国最丑的男人。米拉波，是的。是的，他的脸。好吧，是的。所以有很多受害者
with unpleasant skin complaints. So Brienne had been an opposition figure and he had said, like a lot of the notables, I think Callan's stuff about the deficit is boulderdash.
患有令人不快的皮肤病。所以布里安曾是一个反对派人物，他像许多显贵一样说，我认为卡隆关于赤字的事情是胡说八道。
I don't think there really is a deficit. Let's have a look in the books and just check. There'll be loads of money. And he looks at the books and he says, oh my God.
我不认为真的有赤字。让我们看看账本，核对一下。肯定会有很多钱。他看了看账本，说，天哪。
Well, it's true. Callan wasn't telling the truth about the deficit because he wasn't. It's not 80 million. It's 140 million. Oh, God. And so actually, Brienne then has to go back with his skin complaint to his old chums in the notables. And he says, actually, we do need new taxes. He wants a land tax and a stamp tax.
好吧，这是真的。卡隆在赤字问题上没有说实话，因为他确实没有。不是8000万。是1.4亿。天哪。所以实际上，布里安不得不带着他的皮肤病回到他在显贵中的老朋友那里。他说，实际上，我们确实需要新税。他想要土地税和印花税。
What could possibly go wrong with a stamp tax tom always very successful wheeze and the notables say yet again no we don't either so you know you will have to call the estates general if you want new taxes whatever it is you have to call it so they scrap the assembly of the notables so we're in 1787 and um louis is very very depressed by all this so there are accounts of him saying, you know, he's basically spent all his time now going hunting and drinking and eating. Well, I mean, it's amazing that he can go hunting because he's by this point got incredibly obese.
印花税能出什么问题呢，汤姆？总是非常成功的招数。而显贵们又一次说，不，我们也不要。所以你知道，如果你想要新税，你就必须召集三级会议。无论如何，你必须召集它。所以他们废除了显贵会议。我们现在在1787年，嗯，路易对此感到非常非常沮丧。所以有报道说他基本上现在把所有时间都花在打猎、喝酒和吃东西上。好吧，我的意思是，他能去打猎真是令人惊奇，因为他此时已经变得极其肥胖了。
Yeah. So you pity the horse that has to carry him. Yeah. He's getting very fat. He is very fat, but it's a sad fat, Tom, not a jolly fat. Oh, definitely. He's not a jolly man. No.
是的。所以你同情那匹必须驮着他的马。是的。他变得非常胖。他确实非常胖，但那是一种悲伤的肥胖，汤姆，而不是快乐的肥胖。哦，绝对。他不是一个快乐的人。不。
He's a sad fat man. He's a sad fat man because I think he can see that this is going to be really difficult. Because what options does he have? I mean, every option is bad. So Brienne and Louis get together and they, what are we going to do? They have two options. One is they could just do what everyone says and call this a states general. But the issue with that is once you open that box, one of Simon Sharma's boxes, where's it going to lead?
他是一个悲伤的胖子。他是一个悲伤的胖子，因为我认为他能看出这将是非常困难的。因为他有什么选择呢？我的意思是，每一个选择都很糟糕。所以布里安和路易聚在一起，他们，我们该怎么办？他们有两个选择。一个是他们可以照大家说的做，召集这个三级会议。但问题是，一旦你打开那个盒子，西蒙·沙马的盒子之一，它会通向哪里？
Will they demand more power? Will you basically be reduced to being a British constitutional monarch? And Louis doesn't really want that for obvious reasons. I mean, why would you? You'd want to keep as much power as possible. The other thing they could do is they could go back to the old traditional thing of going through these courts, these parlement, and somehow persuade or bully them into approving the new taxes. And Brienne says, look, I'll do that. So he goes to the Paris parlement, summer of 1787. How about a stamp and tax? How about a land tax, lads? And the parlement of Paris say, no way. And they reject them in groundbreaking language. They say, the days when
他们会要求更多的权力吗？你会基本上沦为一个英国式的君主立宪制国王吗？路易并不真正想要那样，原因显而易见。我的意思是，你为什么要那样？你会想尽可能多地保留权力。他们可以做的另一件事是，他们可以回到通过这些法院，即高等法院的传统做法，并以某种方式说服或胁迫他们批准新税。布里安说，看，我会那样做的。所以他去了巴黎高等法院，1787年夏天。来个印花税怎么样？来个土地税怎么样，伙计们？而巴黎高等法院说，没门。他们用开创性的语言拒绝了他们。他们说，那个时代，
kings just ask for taxes are gone. Absolutism is over and the king must be governed by the law. The nation must give its consent to new taxes with regular meetings of the Estates General. And for the first time, they use a word to describe their fellow Frenchmen that had not been used before by such institutions. They don't call them subjects to the king. They call them citoyens, citizens. But the thing that's amazing about this is that it's in defense of nobles and clergy not paying tax. Yeah, it is. All this kind of language that will be used in the revolution that consumes both the church and the nobility is first being used to defend the privileges of the church and the
国王只是要求税收的时代已经过去了。绝对主义已经结束，国王必须受法律管辖。国家必须通过定期召开三级会议来同意新税。而且他们第一次使用了一个词来描述他们的法国同胞，这是以前这些机构从未用过的。他们不称他们为国王的臣民。他们称他们为“公民”（citoyens）。但令人惊奇的是，这是在捍卫贵族和神职人员不纳税的立场。是的，确实。所有这些将在革命中使用的语言，消耗了教会和贵族，最初却被用来捍卫教会和
nobility. It is. It's bonkers, isn't it? And I think there's two things there. One is that there's a degree of self-interest, obviously. The idea that all the nobility. It is bonkers, isn't it? And I think there's two things there. One is that there's a degree of self-interest, obviously. The idea that all the nobility are like this sort of Dickensian vicomtes who are like whipping their peasants and forcing themselves on poor women and stuff. A lot of these people are actually quite liberal. They have absorbed the language of the Americans, of the American colonists, and they genuinely believe in the Estates General. They actually do like the idea of a British constitutional monarchy.
贵族的特权。这太疯狂了，不是吗？我认为这里有两件事。一是显然存在一定程度的私利。认为所有贵族都像那种狄更斯笔下的子爵，鞭打农民，强迫穷人妇女之类的想法。这些人中有很多实际上相当开明。他们吸收了美国人、美国殖民者的语言，他们真诚地相信三级会议。他们确实喜欢君主立宪制的想法。
And we talked about one of them in the previous episode, Philippe, the Duke of Orléans, whose Palais Real in the centre of Paris is the great centre of free speech of the pamphlets and will be the centre for the Jacopo. Yeah, exactly. So there are people who genuinely, it's partly self-interest, but there are people, I mean, let's not pretend that there aren't people who genuinely
我们在上一集谈到了其中一位，奥尔良公爵菲利普（Philippe, Duke of Orléans），他在巴黎市中心的王宫（Palais Royal）是小册子言论自由的伟大中心，也将成为雅各宾派的中心。是的，完全正确。所以有些人是真诚的，这部分是出于私利，但有些人，我的意思是，我们不要假装没有真诚的人，
believe this and really do think that making a huge fuss about these taxes is a great way to get what they want in the long run, which is basically the British system, the system that had been advocated by the great Enlightenment writer Montesquieu. Let's have that in France, separation of powers, a proper legislature, prime ministers, all of that kind of stuff. Anyway, Brienne is outraged that the parliament has rejected his plan. And he now does a couple of very, very drastic things. First of all, the parliament is exiled to Troyes in August. And literally, it is sealed off by the Swiss guard, by an elite unit of the French army, and they're all basically kicked out. And the reaction to that in Paris is total bedlam.
相信这一点，并且真的认为对这些税收大惊小怪是实现他们长期目标的绝佳方式，这基本上就是英国制度，即伟大的启蒙作家孟德斯鸠所倡导的制度。让我们在法国实现这一点，权力分立，一个适当的立法机构，首相，所有这些东西。总之，布里安对高等法院拒绝了他的计划感到愤怒。他现在做了几件非常非常激进的事情。首先，高等法院在8月被流放到特鲁瓦（Troyes）。而且字面上，它被瑞士卫队，法国军队的一支精锐部队封锁了，他们基本上都被赶走了。而巴黎对此的反应是彻底的混乱。
So if you had a time machine, you went to Paris in 1787 and you got out, you would think you got the settings wrong. You got the settings wrong. Because you'd think, whoa, this is the French Revolution. Because there is rioting by the clerks. People who are giving out royal edicts are attacked by the crowd and two of them almost beaten to death a suspected police agent is beaten to death by the crowd and the government eventually has to send in infantry units to secure the streets of the capital and they end up shutting down loads of clubs and societies they even shut down chess
所以如果你有一台时间机器，你去了1787年的巴黎，你走出来，你会认为你设置错了。你设置错了。因为你会想，哇，这就是法国大革命。因为书记员们在暴动。分发皇家法令的人受到人群的攻击，其中两人几乎被活活打死，一名疑似警察特工被人群活活打死，政府最终不得不派遣步兵部队来确保首都街道的安全，他们最终关闭了大量的俱乐部和社团，他们甚至关闭了国际象棋
clubs because they don't want subversive ideas to spread and there's the real sense from 1787 from this point that the capital is dare i say a tinderbox tom i mean is it more than a tinderbox has it already slipped royal control i think to some degree it has slipped royal control actually and i think from 1787 all the way through to 1789 it's a question of trying to regain royal control and there are troops on the streets pretty much all the time. There was the queen being forbidden by the king to go into Paris. Exactly. So that's against this backdrop, isn't it?
俱乐部，因为他们不想让颠覆性的思想传播。从1787年开始，从这一点开始，有一种真正的感觉，即首都，我敢说，是一个火药桶，汤姆。我的意思是，它不仅仅是一个火药桶，它已经脱离了皇室的控制了吗？我认为在某种程度上它已经脱离了皇室的控制。而且我认为从1787年一直到1789年，这是一个试图重新获得皇室控制权的问题，而且街上几乎一直都有军队。国王禁止王后去巴黎。完全正确。所以这是在这样的背景下，不是吗？
The hostility to Marie Antoinette. So the months pass very uneasily, and then in April 1788, Brienne unveils a new plan to try and break the deadlock. And it's quite clever in a way. What he does is he will strip these courts, the parliament, of their ability to kind of police royal edicts. He will beef up the powers of the courts below them, the lower courts. They'll take over a lot of the
对玛丽·安托瓦内特的敌意。所以几个月不安地过去了，然后在1788年4月，布里安公布了一项新计划，试图打破僵局。这在某种程度上相当聪明。他所做的是剥夺这些法院，即高等法院，监督皇家法令的能力。他将加强他们下级法院，即地方法院的权力。他们将接管高等法院的许多
parliament's power. And there'll be a new court set up, a plenary court, which will approve royal taxes. And obviously he will stuff that court with his people. And the parliament will just be reduced to basically arbitrating disputes among the nobility, which is a pretty pitiful kind of thing for them to be doing. And again, there are massive riots in Paris. There's great outpouring of rage. But the interesting thing here, so much of the French Revolution story is told about Paris. And you just assume the rest of the country is being dragged along in Paris's wake. But that's not the case because the worst riots about the Brienne's Parliament plan are in places like Lyon and Aix and Dijon. So provincial capitals where having a high court
权力。并且将建立一个新的法院，一个全体法院（plenary court），它将批准皇家税收。显然他会用他的人填满那个法院。而高等法院将基本上被降级为仲裁贵族之间的纠纷，这对他们来说是一件相当可悲的事情。同样，巴黎发生了大规模的骚乱。有巨大的愤怒宣泄。但这里有趣的是，法国大革命的故事有太多是关于巴黎的。你只是假设全国其他地方都被巴黎拖着走。但事实并非如此，因为关于布里安高等法院计划的最严重的骚乱发生在里昂、普罗旺斯地区艾克斯（Aix）和第戎（Dijon）等地。所以省会城市，拥有高等法院
was very important to them. Yeah. I mean, it's not surprising, is it? Because we talked about how France is a much more geographically diffuse country than, say, Britain. Yeah. Well, actually, you know, I mean, it's a bit like Scotland defending its distinctiveness against London, that what makes you distinctive is incredibly important to you. Yes. Imagine the government trying to scrap the courts in Scotland and saying, let's have just one British court. I mean, imagine that, how controversial it would be. You know, or the church or whatever. Exactly.
对他们来说非常重要。是的。我的意思是，这并不令人惊讶，不是吗？因为我们谈到了法国是一个比英国地理上分散得多的国家。是的。好吧，实际上，你知道，我的意思是，这有点像苏格兰捍卫其与伦敦不同的独特性，让你与众不同的东西对你来说极其重要。是的。想象一下政府试图废除苏格兰的法院，说，让我们只有一个英国法院。我的意思是，想象一下，那会有多大的争议。你知道，或者教会什么的。完全正确。
This brings us to the city where the French Revolution begins. And it's an unexpected place, isn't it? It is. So I don't think the French Revolution begins in 1789. I think it begins in 1788. And I think it begins in Grenoble. Yeah. So justify that, Dominic. So Grenoble, city in the foothills
这把我们带到了法国大革命开始的城市。这是一个意想不到的地方，不是吗？确实。所以我不认为法国大革命始于1789年。我认为它始于1788年。而且我认为它始于格勒诺布尔（Grenoble）。是的。那么证明这一点，多米尼克。所以格勒诺布尔，位于阿尔卑斯山脚下，
of the Alps, southeastern France. It calls itself the cradle of the revolution. That's how Grenoble brands itself to this day. It's a very ordinary place, which you might think
法国东南部。它自称为“革命的摇篮”。这就是格勒诺布尔至今为自己打的品牌。这是一个非常普通的地方，你可能会认为
makes it a weird place for the revolution to have begun. But no, the ordinariness is the point. That is precisely why the revolution
这使它成为革命开始的一个奇怪地方。但不是，普通正是重点。这正是为什么革命
begins in Grenoble. Grenoble is basically the capital of the province of Dauphine, a long way from Paris. Its regional distinctiveness matters to it. And there's a parliament in Dauphine, and there are loads of people associated with it, lawyers, journalists, useless writers, all of this kind of thing.
始于格勒诺布尔。格勒诺布尔基本上是多菲内省（Dauphine）的首府，离巴黎很远。它的区域独特性对它很重要。多菲内有一个高等法院，有大量与之相关的人，律师、记者、无用的作家，所有这些东西。
The kind of people you get on Twitter. Yeah, exactly that. People who spend all day sitting behind their computers firing off angry messages. They owe their livelihoods to that court. If it is downgraded or removed, they will lose that. Also, Grenoble is a glove-making centre. And they're very good at making gloves.
你在推特上看到的那种人。是的，完全是那样。整天坐在电脑后面发送愤怒信息的人。他们靠那个法院谋生。如果它被降级或移除，他们就会失去那个。此外，格勒诺布尔是一个手套制造中心。他们非常擅长制造手套。
They export them all over the world to America, to Russia. But the glove-making business is in real trouble because all of these woes have led to an economic downturn and lots of people have been put out of work. So there's a lot of anger. So on Saturday, the 7th of June, 1788, the day the French Revolution begins, Brienne has his edict read out in the marketplace. It's market day. And he has troops go to basically take the parliament leaders out of Grenoble, which is what he's trying to do across the kingdom, to take them out of their centres. And the law clerks come out and they start haranguing people and shouting at people in the marketplace. This is what's happening.
他们把它们出口到世界各地，出口到美国，出口到俄罗斯。但手套制造业陷入了真正的困境，因为所有这些苦难导致了经济衰退，许多人失业了。所以有很多愤怒。所以1788年6月7日，星期六，法国大革命开始的那一天，布里安让人在市场上宣读了他的法令。那是集市日。他让军队去，基本上把高等法院的领导人从格勒诺布尔带走，这就是他试图在整个王国做的事情，把他们从他们的中心带走。法律书记员出来，他们开始在市场上向人们发表长篇大论，对人们大喊大叫。这就是正在发生的事情。
Isn't this terrible? And it basically escalates from a protest to a general strike and then a huge riot. They close the city gates. They lay siege to the governor's house. The authorities send in soldiers, but not enough. People go up to the roofs of their houses and they get these tiles and they start bombarding the soldiers with tiles.
这不可怕吗？它基本上从抗议升级为总罢工，然后是一场巨大的骚乱。他们关闭了城门。他们围攻了总督府。当局派出了士兵，但不够多。人们爬上房顶，他们拿着瓦片，开始用瓦片轰炸士兵。
So it goes down in history as the Day of the Tiles. The soldiers, as is so predictable, they lose their cool. They start shooting. They kill a 12-year-old boy and they kill a hatter. And then the crowd go ballistic. They're parading the blooded clothes of these people around they start ringing the bells to summon peasants in from the countryside because of course because it's market day a lot of people have come in from the countryside already so they're sent sailing to
所以它作为“瓦片之日”（Day of the Tiles）载入史册。士兵们，正如预料的那样，他们失去了冷静。他们开始开枪。他们杀了一个12岁的男孩和一个制帽匠。然后人群彻底炸锅了。他们游行展示这些人的血衣，他们开始敲钟召集乡下的农民，因为当然，因为是集市日，很多人已经从乡下进城了，所以他们被派去
the peasants your relatives are under attack from the soldiers come and defend them quickly so people are pouring into the city. Basically, the crowd seizes. The mob seizes the city. They sack the governor's house. Tom, you'll be gutted about this. They ransacked the governor's natural history cabinet. I saw that.
农民们，你们的亲戚正受到士兵的攻击，快来保卫他们，所以人们涌入城市。基本上，人群占领了。暴徒占领了城市。他们洗劫了总督府。汤姆，你会为此感到难过的。他们洗劫了总督的自然历史陈列柜。我看到了。
And they took the stuffed eagle. Stuffed eagle. That's terrible. Yeah. I suppose you can't make an omelette without breaking eggs. Well, of course, as famously as has been remarked on this podcast, they do not actually make the omelette. So basically there is an intra-elite attempt to kind of grab the levers of power. But essentially that fight between the kind of rival sections of the elite has been overtaken by a mass uprising.
他们拿走了那只填充的老鹰。填充的老鹰。那太可怕了。是的。我想不打破鸡蛋就做不成煎蛋卷。好吧，当然，正如在这个播客上著名地评论过的那样，他们实际上并没有做成那个煎蛋卷。所以基本上，精英内部试图夺取权力杠杆。但本质上，精英中竞争派系之间的那种斗争已经被大规模起义所取代。
Yeah, it has. And actually, Simon Sharma is absolutely brilliant on this. It's one of the many, many fantastic insights in his book. And we shouldn't make this the Sharma fan cast, but he points out the judges are carried aloft by the crowd, the parliament judges. But he says it's not clear at this point. They're not the leaders of the riot.
是的，确实。而且实际上，西蒙·沙马对此非常出色。这是他书中许多许多精彩见解之一。我们不应该把这变成沙马粉丝播客，但他指出法官们被人群高高举起，那些高等法院的法官。但他说是的，这一点尚不清楚。他们不是骚乱的领导者。
They're kind of its trophies, a bit like the stuffed eagle, but they're also kind of its prisoners. Right. And this is something that will happen again and again. So, I mean, looking ahead, it's an experience that the royal family will soon be experiencing. Yeah. And some of the older judges are very anxious about this and end up actually leaving the city. They don't want to be associated with this. But there's a younger generation who are enthused and actually see in the disorder and the collapse of royal authority a chance to lead, to profit. And the classic example of this is a guy who I think you can argue is the first true French revolutionary leader. So he's a young judge from Grenoble and he's called Jean-Joseph Meunier. And he is just such a perfect example of a French revolutionary leader.
他们有点像它的战利品，有点像那只填充的老鹰，但他们也某种程度上是它的囚犯。没错。这是会一次又一次发生的事情。所以，我的意思是，展望未来，这是王室很快就会经历的体验。是的。一些年长的法官对此非常焦虑，最终实际上离开了城市。他们不想与此有任何关联。但有一代年轻人很热心，实际上在混乱和皇权的崩溃中看到了领导、获利的机会。而这方面的典型例子是一个人，我认为你可以说他是第一个真正的法国革命领袖。所以他是一位来自格勒诺布尔的年轻法官，名叫让-约瑟夫·穆尼耶（Jean-Joseph Mounier）。他是一个完美的法国革命领袖的例子。
He's the son of a cloth merchant. He's upwardly mobile. He's 29, so he's young, as so many of them were. And he's a lawyer. They're all lawyers. They're all young lawyers. And he's really ambitious. They're basically like Athelstan members, Tom.
他是布商的儿子。他积极向上。他29岁，所以他很年轻，就像他们中的许多人一样。他是一名律师。他们都是律师。他们都是年轻的律师。而且他非常有野心。他们基本上就像埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）成员，汤姆。
They're young lawyers of the Restless History Club. French revolutionaries in waiting. So he has bought the office of a royal judge and he has actually become a very, very, he's on the lowest possible rank of the nobility. And isn't that always the way, classically, in a revolution? It's not the poor, it's always the uply mobile who haven't got quite uply mobile enough. Exactly. And he sees this as a chance to jump up the ladder and to turn the ladder into his ladder. So he convenes a huge meeting on the 21st of July, 1788, outside Grenoble at the Chateau de Vizelle. The Chateau de Vizelle, if you go there today, it is the world's only museum of the French Revolution. And there's a reason for that.
他们是“历史的余味”俱乐部的年轻律师。等待中的法国革命者。所以他买了一个皇家法官的职位，他实际上已经成为一个非常非常，他处于贵族最低的等级。这难道不是革命中总是那样吗？不是穷人，总是那些积极向上但还没爬得足够高的人。完全正确。他把这看作是一个跳上梯子并把梯子变成他自己的梯子的机会。所以他在1788年7月21日，在格勒诺布尔外的维齐耶城堡（Chateau de Vizille）召集了一次巨大的会议。维齐耶城堡，如果你今天去那里，它是世界上唯一的法国大革命博物馆。这是有原因的。
Because you can argue, again, this is one of the absolute places where the French Revolution began. Well, particularly if you were the Grenoble Tourist Board. If you're the Grenoble Tourist Board, exactly. And at this meeting, he says, listen, we want free elections. We want the Estates General of Dauphine, each province to have its own Estates General. And when that meets, the third estate, the Commons, should have the same numbers as the other two estates, the Lords and the Clergy, put together. And they should all sit in one chamber, not multiple chambers like they have in Britain, lords and commons, or one chamber so that
因为你可以说，同样，这是法国大革命开始的绝对地点之一。好吧，特别是如果你是格勒诺布尔旅游局的话。如果你是格勒诺布尔旅游局，完全正确。在这次会议上，他说，听着，我们要自由选举。我们要多菲内的三级会议，每个省都要有自己的三级会议。当它召开时，第三等级，即平民，应该拥有与其他两个等级，即贵族和神职人员加起来一样多的席位。而且他们都应该坐在一个议院里，而不是像英国那样有多个议院，贵族院和平民院，或者一个议院，这样
the commons can dominate. In other words, majority rule, the general will, will dominate over the privileges of the old order. And a lot of historians say that is so groundbreaking and seismic that that is the true kickoff point for the revolution, the chain of events that will lead to the revolution. There's two other things that I think are really revealing about that meeting at Wiesel. First of all is the language is so 1793. It's all about patriotic fire, sacrifices. The law should be the expression of the general will. But the other thing is there is a darker side to it. So for the first time, these people say, we are patriots, but our opponents are traitors to the patrie and they should be treated accordingly.
平民就可以主导。换句话说，多数原则，国民意志，将主导旧秩序的特权。许多历史学家说，这具有开创性和震撼性，是革命的真正起点，是导致革命的一系列事件的开端。我认为关于维齐耶的那次会议还有两件事非常具有启发性。首先是语言太像1793年了。全是关于爱国热情、牺牲。法律应该是国民意志的表达。但另一件事是，它有黑暗的一面。所以第一次，这些人说，我们是爱国者，但我们的对手是祖国的叛徒，他们应该受到相应的对待。
Because there's a kind of incipiently totalitarian quality to saying that you are the embodiment of the nation. Definitely there is, Tom. Because if you are the embodiment of the nation, your enemies therefore aren't, and by definition are traitors. Yeah, I totally agree with you. Now, of course, you can say there's a great irony here, that actually even Meunier and his friends have not really understood what happened in Grenoble that riotous day. They think, because they've been chaired aloft by the crowd, they think they're going to control it. And they are, of course, dead wrong. And some of these people are going to end up dead, literally dead.
因为声称自己是国家的化身，这本身就带有一种极权主义的萌芽。汤姆，确实如此。因为如果你是国家的化身，那么你的敌人就不是，从定义上讲，他们就是叛徒。是的，我完全同意你的观点。当然，你可以说这里有一个巨大的讽刺，实际上即使是穆尼耶和他的朋友们，也没有真正理解在格勒诺布尔那个暴乱的日子里发生了什么。他们以为，因为被人群高高抬起，他们就能控制局面。当然，他们大错特错了。这些人中的一些人最终会死，字面意义上的死亡。
But I think what makes it so revealing is that it is indicative of this change in the language and the sentiment that is happening in 1788. Previously, all that stuff was about the old liberties of the French, that the government, a modernising government, is trying to squash. But in 1788, you can see that language changing, and people are now saying, let's actually do something new. Who cares about the past? We can use this opportunity to draw up a new constitution charmer gives a brilliant example of a lawyer called volney who wrote a journal
但我认为最能说明问题的是，它预示了1788年语言和情感上的这种变化。此前，所有这些讨论都是关于法国人的旧有自由，而政府，一个现代化的政府，正试图压制这些自由。但在1788年，你可以看到这种语言正在改变，人们现在说，让我们做点新的事情吧。谁在乎过去呢？我们可以利用这个机会起草一部新宪法。夏尔马举了一个绝妙的例子，一位名叫沃尔内的律师写了一本杂志，
called the sentinel of the people what does it matter to us what our fathers have done or how and why they have done it the essential rights of man his natural relations to his fellows in the state of society these are the basis of any form of government. So in other words, they're going to take that, the idea of starting again, and they take the passion, the idea of virtue, all of that. And that gives them, you could argue, what Robert Danton calls a radically simplified view of politics. Well, and also, I mean, it's very contrary to the way that the constitution has evolved in Britain, where the whole point of the relationship of the monarchy to the House of Lords and the House of Commons has evolved over time and is rooted in the deep past. And so therefore, you can already
名为《人民哨兵》。它写道：我们的祖先做了什么，或者他们如何以及为何这样做，这对我们有什么关系？人的基本权利，他在社会状态中与同胞的自然关系，这些才是任何政府形式的基础。换句话说，他们要采纳这种从头开始的想法，并带入激情、美德的概念等等。你可以说，这给了他们罗伯特·丹东所称的“激进简化的政治观”。嗯，而且，我的意思是，这与英国宪法的演变方式截然相反，在英国，君主制与上议院和下议院的关系的全部意义在于随着时间的推移而演变，并植根于深远的过去。因此，你已经可以
see that Britain is starting to fade as a model for the more radical proponents of a new constitution. But also what is so interesting is it is also different from the American constitution makers because the American constitution makers are slightly trapped within the British mindset. So there it's about the separation of powers. They want to ensure against a kind of mob democracy. They want to ensure against somebody having too much power. Their constitution is hedged about with kind of nuances and qualifications. The French revolutionists have no time for that.
看出英国作为新宪法激进支持者的模式正在逐渐淡出。但同样有趣的是，这也与美国的制宪者不同，因为美国的制宪者在某种程度上被困在英国的思维模式中。所以那里讨论的是权力分立。他们想要防止某种暴民民主。他们想要防止某人拥有过大的权力。他们的宪法充满了各种细微差别和限定条件。法国革命者对此毫无耐心。
Sharma quotes a guy who was a friend of Rousseau's called the Comte d'Entregue, who said, The people is the state itself. By the immutable laws of nature, the people is everything. Everything should be subordinated to the people. That is not how British Whig politicians spoke. It's not really how American colonists spoke. This sense of, it's very simple. There's us, the side of virtue and patriotism and liberty.
夏尔马引用了卢梭的朋友德·昂特雷格伯爵的话，他说：“人民就是国家本身。根据自然的不变法则，人民就是一切。一切都应从属于人民。”这不是英国辉格党政客说话的方式。这也不是美国殖民者说话的方式。这种感觉非常简单。有我们，代表美德、爱国主义和自由的一方。
And then there's them, despotism and depredations and corruption and all of that. And traitors. And traitors. So right there, even before the fall of the Bastille, you've got the lines being drawn very starkly. Now, meanwhile, Mr. Brienne, with his pustules, the archbishop is sitting there in Versailles thinking, what on earth am I going to do?
然后是他们，代表专制、掠夺、腐败等等。还有叛徒。还有叛徒。所以就在那里，甚至在巴士底狱陷落之前，界限就已经非常鲜明地划定了。现在，与此同时，布里安先生，那个长着脓疱的大主教，正坐在凡尔赛宫思考，我到底该怎么办？
And clearly everything is all kicked off. His plan hasn't really worked. And he says to Louis, listen, we do have to call the Estates General. We're going to have to do this. And Louis says to him, what archbishop? You must think we are lost. They might overturn the state and the monarchy. And Brienne says, I'm afraid we have no choice at all.
显然一切都乱套了。他的计划并没有真正奏效。他对路易说，听着，我们确实必须召集三级会议。我们必须这样做。路易对他说，什么，大主教？你一定认为我们完了。他们可能会推翻国家和君主制。布里安说，恐怕我们别无选择。
So in the second week of August 1788, they go public and they say, we're going to call the Estates General. We'll figure out how it will work in due course. We don't really know what the rules will be, how it will be elected, but we will call it all the same. What could possibly go wrong and then against this background a massive development on the 16th of august brienne announces they have run out of money they have been surviving all this time on loans but the royal treasury is virtually empty from now on people will be paid in ious in paper money which they don't really believe exists which they hate in other words france is bankrupt well dominic what a cliffhanger so in the next episode the estates general will be meeting the revolution will be beginning or if you accept that it's already begun in grenoble it will be continuing and if you just can't wait
因此，在1788年8月的第二周，他们公开宣布，我们将召集三级会议。我们会在适当的时候弄清楚它将如何运作。我们并不真正知道规则会是什么，如何选举，但我们还是会召集它。还有什么可能出错呢？然后在此背景下，8月16日发生了一个重大进展，布里安宣布他们没钱了。他们一直靠贷款维持到现在，但皇家国库几乎空了。从现在起，人们将用欠条支付，用他们并不真正相信存在的纸币支付，他们讨厌这种纸币。换句话说，法国破产了。好吧，多米尼克，真是个悬念。所以在下一集中，三级会议将召开，革命将开始，或者如果你认为它已经在格勒诺布尔开始了，那么它将继续进行。如果你等不及了，
to find out what happens you can hear it right now by joining the Restless History Club at therestlesshistory.com alternatively the next episode will be coming very soon
想知道发生了什么，你可以通过加入therestlesshistory.com的“Restless History Club”立即收听。或者，下一集很快就会推出。
either way we'll see you then bye bye bye bye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment It's your weekly fix
无论如何，到时候见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你的每周固定节目，
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works We have just launched
包含娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our Members Club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。